مشروب واحد يمكن أن يكون له بعض الفوائد
ما نعرفه أنه يمكن أن
يقلل من خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب وعلى
وجه التحديد قد يقلل من بعض
الالتهابات في جسمك وأيضًا
احتمالية الإصابة بجلطات الدم الآن
إذا بدأت في المبالغة في
هذه الفوائد بسرعة  تمحى
بسبب تأثير أعضاء أخرى في
جسمك وحتى عقلك على الكبد ، فإن
مشكلة الكحول هي أنك إذا كنت
تحاول مراقبة السعرات
الحرارية التي تتناولها ، فإن تناول السعرات الحرارية هو أسوأ شيء يمكنك القيام به
إذا كنت تشرب كوبًا.  في اليوم الذي
تشرب فيه ما يقرب من ألف سعر حراري في
الأسبوع ، لذلك إذا كنت تشرب 2000
سعر حراري في الأسبوع ، فإنك تقترب من
نصف رطل أسبوعيًا من الوزن الإضافي
فقط من الكحول ، وأعتقد أن هناك
بعض القواعد الذهبية عندما يتعلق الأمر
الشرب ، من الواضح أنك لا تريد
أن تشرب كثيرًا
لرجل أكثر من 14 مرة في الأسبوع بالنسبة للمرأة سبع مرات
في الأسبوع ، فأنت لا ترغب أبدًا في مزجها
مع أدوية أخرى أو
عقاقير أخرى ولا ترغب أبدًا في ذلك  اجلس
خلف عجلة القيادة ولكن القليل من الكحول
كل يوم يمكن أن يساعدك على العيش
حتى 100